THERE IS THIS FROM SENATOR CRUZ.
>> LAST MONTH OVER 100,000
ILLEGAL ALIENS WERE DETAINED AT
THE BORDER AND IT IS GETTING
WORSE.
WE’RE SEEING IN PARTICULAR MORE
AND MORE KIDS, UNACCOMPANIED
KIDS, YOUNG CHILDREN, KIDS IN
CAGES AS THE MEDIA TOLD US FOR
FOUR YEARS RELENTLESSLY DURING
DONALD TRUMP.
THERE ARE A LOT MORE KIDS IN
CAGES RIGHT NOW.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOESN’T WANT ANYONE TO KNOW
THIS.
>> Dana: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CAVING TO THE
INTENSE PRESSURE GRANTING
LIMITED MEDIA ACCESS FOR A
HOLDING CENTER FOR MIGRANT
CHILDREN LATER TODAY.
SENIOR WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
SET TO VISIT MEXICO AND
GUATEMALA TOMORROW IN A BID TO
STEM THE OVERWHELMING SURGE OF
MIGRANTS CROSSING THE BORDER IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
FORMER ACTING DIRECTOR OF
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT AND LISTEN
TO ANOTHER PIECE OF SOUND BY
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS ABOUT THE
BORDER.
>> WILL YOU AND THE PRESIDENT
BEING TO THE BORDER ANY TIME
SOON?
>> ABSOLUTE SLI.
I’VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
OUR SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY HAS BEEN DOWN THERE
TWICE AND YES, WE WILL GO.
>> Dana: THE VISITS DON’T
TRANSLATE INTO ANY CHANGE IN
POLICY, AT LEAST NOT YET.
>> THEY CAN MAKE ALL TRIPS TO
THE BORDER THEY WANT.
UNTIL THEY UNDO THE DAMAGING
POLICIES OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THINGS AREN’T
GOING TO CHANGE.
YOU MENTIONED THEY’RE GOING TO
MEXICO AND GUATEMALA TO MEET
WITH OFFICIALS TRYING TO COME
TO SOME AGREEMENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THEM
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD AGREEMENTS
WITH GUATEMALA, EL SALVADOR,
HONDURAS AND MEXICO THAT THEY
TORE UP.
WHY DO THAT WHEN THEY’RE THE
SOURCE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
TO HELP STEM THE FLOW.
IT’S RIDICULOUS.
IN SUCH A HURRY UNDOING
EVERYTHING TRUMP THEY PUT
THEMSELVES IN THIS CRISIS.
ONE THING THAT TED CRUZ WAS
RIGHT WHEN HE SAID.
I WANT TO ADD ONE MORE THING TO
WHAT HE SAID.
100,000 A MONTH.
THERE ARE OVER 1,000 A DAY ARE
GETTING AWAY BECAUSE OF DRONE
TRAFFIC AND ENTRIES THAT THEY
CAN’T RESPOND TO BECAUSE
THEY’RE BUSY WITH FAMILIES.
OVER 30,000 GETTING BY THE
BORDER PATROL IN A MONTH.
WHO ARE THEY?
DO THEY HAVE COVID?
ARE THEY CRIMINALS AND CARRYING
DRUGS, FENTANYL, OPIOIDS?
THAT’S WHAT MAKES IT A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
>> Bill: MAYORKAS WORKED THE
BORDER ISSUE FOR OBAMA FOR 7 OR
8 YEARS AND KNEW THE PLAN AND
POLICY ONCE IMPLY METED.
WHAT IS WORKING AND WHAT’S NOT.
THE ONLY REASON WHY THEY
CHANGED THE AGREEMENT WITH
MEXICO, THE ONLY REASON THEY
CHANGED THE AGREEMENTS WITH
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES IS
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP HAD
AGREEMENT WITH THEM?
IF THAT’S THE CASE, THEY KNEW
WHAT THE EFFECT WOULD BE.
WE’VE BEEN ASKING PEOPLE EVERY
TIME THEY COME ON AREA?
IF YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY HOW THIS
IS GOING TO TURN OUT, WHY DO IT?
ANSWER THAT, SIR.
>> I WROTE AN OP-ED IN JUNE OF
LAST YEAR, EIGHT MONTHS AGO AND
SAID THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I SAID EVERY ONE OF THESE
THINGS WOULD HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
THE PROMISES BIDEN WAS MAKING
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
I SAID ON NUMEROUS SHOWS, THIS
IS BY DESIGN.
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT AND
MAYORKAS WAS DEPUTY SECRETARY
AND MET WITH HIM NUMEROUS TIMES.
WHAT CAUSES SURGES AND HOW TO
END IT.
HOW DO WE END IT IN 1415, WE
BUILT THOUSANDS OF DETENTION
BEDS AND DETAINED PEOPLE AND
DETAINED UNTIL THEY SAW A JUDGE.
90% LOST THEIR CASES.
ICE REMOVED THEM.
WE TOOK AWAY THE ENTICEMENTS.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING NOW?
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE BY DESIGN.
THEY’RE RELEASING PEOPLE AS
QUICK AS THEY CAN.
ICE HAS BEEN GUTTED.
THEY AREN’T DEPORTING EVERYONE
AND NOW THEY’RE OFFERING MORE
ENTICE ALSO.
PROCESS THEM AND NOT GIVE THEM
A COURT DATE AND LEAVE IT TO
THEM TO SHOW UP TO COURT?
ENTICEMENTS ARE ADDED.
THEY ARE DOING EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THEY KNOW WILL
STOP THE SURGE.
THIS IS NOT INCOMPETENCE OR A
MISTAKE.
THIS IS BY DESIGN.
THIS IS WHAT OPEN BORDERS LOOKS
LIKE.
JOE BIDEN HAS SOLD OUT THIS
COUNTRY AND OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND OUR BORDER
SECURITY TO WIN AN ELECTION.
THERE IS NO OTHER EXCUSE.
YOU CAN GET ON TV AND LIE ABOUT
IT AND SAY IT IS NOT A CRISIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE US THE
MOST SECURE BORDER IN MY CAREER
IN 35 YEARS.
THEY’VE TORN IT APART IN TWO
WEEKS.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS INTEGRITY.
GET ON NATIONAL TV AND TELL THE
TRUTH TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT IS ALMOST EMBARRASSING TO
HEAR THEM DENIGHT AND TRY TO
FLIP IT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
GAVE US THE MOST SECURE BORDER
I HAVE EVER SEEN.
>> Dana: LOOK FORWARD TO